I think we need to get comfortable as a
culture in trying to understand our
species and how we work that the early
stages of hard work and focus are going
to feel like agitation stress and
confusion because that's the
norepinephrine adrenaline system kicking
in none of us would expect to walk into
the gym and do our PR lift or performer
go do something without warming up the
brain also needs to warm up and start to
hone in which circuits are going to be
active and it's unreasonable for us to
think oh I've got an hour I'm going to
plop down and write beautifully for an
hour my best work we need to accept that
there's a period of agitation and stress
that accompanies the dropping into these
highly concentrated States now in terms
of the reward that accompanies the
feeling that we're funneling into that
groove of being productive in one regime
like for you writing this book The
dopamine system is really important to
understand the dopamine system is Mother
Nature's hard-wired ancient system in
all animals including humans to put us
on the right path